muslim and hindu students in india face
off on the right to wear head scarves in
class so is this a religious issue or a
broader debate on minority rights and
identity in india
this is inside storage
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim jom india's constitution
guarantees a secular state and religious
freedom but minority muslims say they
face increasing harassment and
discrimination from the hindu majority
the latest controversy revolves around a
ban on headscarves in school it started
last month when six muslim female
students in karnataka state protested
against being barred from class hindu
students held counter demonstrations
wearing scarves in saffron a color
associated with hindu nationalism
right-wing groups have been accused of
fueling the dispute the state has shut
down schools until friday while its high
court considers the issue we'll bring in
our guests in a moment but first this
report from padme matal in new delhi
videos that define the growing tensions
in the state of karnataka in southern
india students aligned with hindu groups
heckler woman for wearing a bulkha as
competing religious chants are heard
every religion has freedom they are
following their culture and i am
following mine they should let us follow
our culture and not raise obstacles for
us
a few weeks ago six teenage students
were barred from wearing headscarves in
the classroom
those protests have now spread across
the state with more women demanding the
right to cover their heads in class
opposing them are hindu groups they've
been marching wearing saffron coloured
scarves and shawls and some hoisted a
saffron flag the colour is considered
sacred by many hindus
uniform is same for everyone whether it
is hindu muslim or christian they should
abide and wear uniform and the hijab has
to be kept outside the gate
the state government run by prime
minister narendra modi's party janta
party has supported school and college
administrators in banning muslim girls
wearing headscarves in class the rao has
reignited the debate about minority
rights in india that these hindu
supremacist groups are the same you know
the self same groups that since 2008 uh
attack women in the same coastal
karnataka area for visiting pubs for
wearing western clothes uh they
valentine's day is coming up and the
same groups will be out on the streets
heckling couples lovers who are sitting
together and saying that you're not
allowed to fertilize uh with somebody
who's not your husband and so on so
these are extremely regressive groups
there is nothing feminist about their uh
objection to hijab
they are merely trying to prevent any uh
you know shrink the spaces for muslims
in
colleges and shrink the spaces for
interaction between hindu and muslim
the state government closed all high
schools and colleges until friday while
the high court judges hear legal
arguments and decide whether or not the
law on constitutional freedoms is being
broken
pavni mithal al-jazeera new delhi
[Music]
all right let's bring in our guests in
new delhi fatima khan a journalist at
the quint
in doha udai chandra assistant professor
of government at georgetown university
and also in new delhi anastanvir
advocate at the supreme court of india
and founder of the indian civil
liberties union a warm welcome to you
all and thank you so much for being on
the program today fatima let me start
with you
how did all this begin in karnataka did
it all just start in the past month with
a handful of students protesting after
they were told they couldn't attend
school if they were wearing the hijab or
or were there other incidents as well
well it started with six odd young women
muslim women who've been wearing the
hijab for years now uh waking up one day
incidentally around new year's
going to their college and being told by
their class teacher that you will not be
allowed inside this classroom until and
unless you take off your hijab um and
that is it and they said that no this is
unacceptable hijab is a part of our
identity hijab is a part of our religion
our faith
and it isn't obstructing you or your
classes in any way or form so let us
think but they were told not uh to enter
with uh with that piece of cloth on
their head um and that is it in these
girls they took it upon themselves to
protest against this arbitrary
absolutely arbitrary policy that was
placed in that college in that one
college incidentally it was a government
college a public institution not a
private institution and in that very
moment they said that look there cannot
be any such policy because as per our
fundamental rights we are allowed to
express ourselves wear the kind of
clothes that we want to um in a way that
isn't harming you in any way or form
one that protests eventually snowballed
into
national news it became national news
and multiple other colleges
pre-university colleges decided to one
day just stop uh muslim women from
entering if they are wearing the hijab
uday fatima there was mentioning um the
difference between um whether it's a
state institution or or a private
institution when it comes to wearing the
hijab i want to ask you i want to take a
step back for a moment were female
students in karnataka state allowed to
wear head scarves to class before that
did it depend upon what kind of
institution they were going to and also
is asking a muslim woman not to wear a
hijab in karnataka or other parts of
india a violation of their rights as
citizens
it's definitely a violation of their
fundamental rights as fatima said i mean
i think that the constitution gives
everyone an equal right to practice and
propagate their religion and uh there
has never been an issue um with people
wearing a you know sick man wearing a
turban or a muslim woman wearing um a
head scarf and i really see that this is
um a kind of deliberate and mischievous
ploy and karnataka is very much a test
ground for certain um tactics really
political tactics um which i suppose uh
before the next national election um
there is a big push for a uniform civil
code and this is something that the
current regime in india would like to
actually see ana's from your perspective
does banning the hijab in these schools
go against the constitutional rights of
these students
uh indeed it does go against the
constitutional right of these students
but most importantly
this is not
per se a matter where
i mean obviously the constitutional
rights are being violated but they are
being violated without the state having
any legal power to do so
the college has never prescribed any
uniform
it's not
that the students are going against the
set norms or going against the uniform
or rebelling now they have always
practiced observed hijab the state has
no legal standing the the law in the in
the state of karnataka the education act
does not give any power to regulate
uniform of the students the law only
regulates the institutions
and
even if there is a mention of uniform it
is only with regard to giving power to
the
school to bring in any uniform which
this school has not done yet
so
this whole exercise
where they are prohibiting and stopping
sometimes violently these students from
entering college while
while wearing hijab is unconstitutional
and against all the set norms of the
law fanta from your vantage point um
these tensions between hindus and
muslims i mean obviously that's nothing
new but the fact that these long-running
tensions are now playing out among a
different generation among younger
people that it's affecting students and
not just middle-aged politicians or
policymakers what does that what does
that say to you
about the state of things in india right
now it's horrific it's absolutely
unfortunate you know i speak to so many
young muslims as part of my job because
i covered communalism i covered social
justice and so many of them have said
that in the last five years
seven odd years they have lost their
friends they have lost their closest
friends people who they never thought
would turn out to be bigots would turn
out to be ignorant but um today they see
them leading this charge of bigotry
leading this charge of anti-muslim hate
anti-muslim all they've lost their
closest pens and i feel personally when
i talk to them i see in their eyes that
nothing can be more heartbreaking than
that not who is leading this country not
who's in power but just the fact that
the people who you thought would never
leave your side like that would never
one day turn around and say these things
in fact the visual um that i'd urge your
viewers to say this young girl wearing
the hijab entering her college driving
to her college on a scooter she's then
trying to enter her class enter the
school and these 30 40 young all men
extremely just young boys bearing the
saffron challenge heckling her harassing
her bullying her from entering um
chanting slogans of gesture
she still manages to hold her head high
and walk in and later in an interview
she said that you know some of them many
of them were outsiders but some of them
were her classmates people she
recognized imagine the trauma that that
an episode like that can leave you with
because it's not some vague authority
who you're rebelling against suddenly
your friends your classmates
udai i saw a tweet of yours where i
believe you were referring to some of
these students
that videos have emerged showing them
as they're trying to go to class and
being heckled by by others there by
other male students many of them wearing
these saffron robes um heckling the
women that are in the hijab um and in
the one of your tweets you said that
some of these female protesters are
showing
more courage than the entire opposition
in india which cannot raise this matter
on the eve of a critical election why in
your opinion can the opposition not
bring this issue up
well i think the the
the bjp the ruling party has really
changed the political discourse uh
increasingly um you have the congress
party trying to also say
hinduism is different from hindutva
which it is perhaps but i think we have
to accept that many of our hindu
classmates and neighbors and compatriots
are our sympathizers of this kind of
communal violence and this kind of
politics and the po and the opposition
um is not willing to take it on
because they recognize that society has
moved in a majoritarian direction so
they find that electorally there is no
incentive for them beyond a few
rhetorical gestures perhaps or the odd
tweet but they are not going to make
this into um a major election issue they
are not going to make this into a
a big debate about the idea of india
itself let me ask you about the fact
that the the high court which is hearing
a petition by muslim girls to allow the
use of hijabs and educational
institutions um well they referred the
case to a bigger panel of judges
was that expected and
from your vantage point what happens now
so the matter was referred by a single
judge
to a larger bench as it is called here
and the larger bench continued the
hearing today
uh some really good submissions were
made from the side of petitioners while
there was a
argument and demand for an interim
belief that while the court hears the
matter let the girls attend the college
let them observe their hijab and enter
the college let them continue with their
study because they have their practical
exams from if i remember correctly from
15th onwards
so however we
the court was not inclined to grant that
relief the mata is now listed for
consideration and argument on monday
and
from my understanding of it
the law stands
as the law stands the court should
in all fairness
in all fairness decide in favor of the
petitioners because
this is their constitutional fundamental
right it is their right to expression
supreme court has held what you wear is
also a part of your right to privacy and
obviously it is also like to
life and liberty
no such action can be no law no action
no executive action can be taken which
is in contravention of the fundamental
rights and that is the case today they
have taken action for which they never
had power and which contravenes the
constitution fatima whenever this um
this ruling is delivered um will there
be other legal avenues available to the
female
students after the ruling is made where
might the case go from here
you know legally i think honest is more
well case to expound on those issues but
i think socially
whatever the ruling may be right these
visuals just look at these visuals
imagine a country where this is playing
out in 21st century 2022 where a young
woman cannot enter her class at a time
when you know we have had the
conversations about women's access to
education for centuries now and suddenly
we are still having to argue that a
section of a certain community should or
should not be allowed access and i would
like to bring this in unfortunately the
discourse in india is such that it is
shifted from that being about
fundamental rights that we are
discussing here tonight too about being
you know
should women be wearing the hijab or not
is it uh is it something that they
should be wearing is it is it something
that they've been forced to wear or not
the kind of conversation uh it's really
astounding to me personally you think
those 30 40 young boys who are heckling
that girl are they feminists of some
sort are they purviewers or some
feminist values was suddenly having this
conversation about choice versus
conditioning no
they are men who are harassing her
purely by virtue of being a muslim woman
and we have to see this in the larger
context of what has been happening with
muslims in the country in karnataka
specifically uh there have been laws
brought in against conversion a forceful
conversion so to say but they've been
used as a pretext to raise churches one
after another uh
in muslim men in interfaith
relationships have been harassed and
abused because they've been forced uh
they've been accused of forcefully
converting
non-muslim women um just a couple of
months ago just earlier this year and
six months before that a list was
brought out where you know muslim women
prominent muslim women journalists
activist poets were auctioned online uh
i incidentally happened to be on both of
those lists so you have to see this in
just this whole tide of disturbing
events one after the other against
muslims
udai i just want to go back for a moment
to the issue of these state elections
that have begun that are going to be
playing out in phases um first of all
i'm curious to know how much you think
the religious issues will become a part
of these elections
will the headscarf issue be a much
bigger part of the elections and also do
you believe that political actors are
going to be trying to capitalize on
these rising tensions
i think the bjp has uh you know it's had
to campaign online in recent weeks uh
and i think this is something through
the tv studios and uh their allies in
the media i think they're very keen to
bring this up to communalize the up
election they don't want to focus on the
incompetence and the poor development um
that is that the last five years and up
has brought
so they want a diversionary narrative
and uh karnataka has
yielded that narrative um i don't think
it's a it's as important an issue in
punjab because after all sikhs could say
that wearing the turban is also their
fundamental right
and it was an issue in the 1980s where
these kinds of things were where six the
anti-sick politics took place but today
this is not an issue so i don't think
it's going to have a spillover effect in
in goa or in um in punjab
anas from your vantage point is what
we're seeing happening right now what's
playing out in karnataka is this
unprecedented
this is not unprecedented
since
eight years now
almost there has been laws to victimize
muslims they have been actioned by
non-state actors to victimize muslims we
have seen as spied in genocidal uh
speeches we have seen that even the
lamas in guruka was
obstructed
and
the state looks the other side either
looks the other side
if he uh
when there's an attack by a non-state
actors or when there's harassment of
muslims either they look the other side
of their complicity
and
it is
not something surprising
they have a problem with the muslim
identity and a muslim woman wearing
observing hijab is an assertion of her
identity as a muslim
and that assertion while protected by
the constitution
makes these uh
goons i'll call them goons makes these
wounds very nervous
and this is a trend towards
victimization and pushing muslims to
the sideline
fatima how concerned are you right now
that the attacks on religious identity
have escalated this much
i'm very concerned you know because in
the last couple of weeks i focused my
reporting on uttar pradesh which
incidentally is going for elections
today and
what i found is that large scale riots
that used to be commonplace in india
have been replaced by events like these
so imagine a muslim woman a young muslim
girl sitting in any part of the country
watching these visuals play out what
kind of an impact would it have on her
psychologically you know it is
essentially sending out a message that
look we can do anything with you at any
point of time we can snatch away any of
the rights that you took for granted um
and you won't be able to do anything
about it so that kind of psychological
messaging i'd say is much more dangerous
than a concerted localized uh riot or
communal violence because it leaves a
much more a longer impact and you know
the prime minister he is repeatedly one
of the catch phrases of this government
have been baked
which means save the girl child educate
the girl child but at this point of time
if you're even debating if muslim women
wearing the hijab should be allowed
access into a classroom we are clearly
taking
many many hundred steps backwards
udai i saw you nodding along to a lot of
what fatima was saying there so it looks
like you wanted to jump in go ahead
um you know i i completely agree with
what fatma's just said and i i really
think that um
the rule of law is now on on
trial and i think you know the fact that
this the high court in karnataka has
deferred the issue itself i think is a
problem and um i think that you know
they could have easily said that these
girls should be able to wear whatever
they want and carry on with their exams
and classes but they chose not to do
this and they chose to make it an issue
where both sides seem to have equally
valid arguments and i think that is
already a problem and uh you know i
think that when fundamental rights are
being violated with impunity uh it sends
a very bad message and it's the same
message that was sent um when namaste
or in open spaces was targeted in
gurgaon just next to delhi um so i think
there are a number of these incidents
micro level incidents in different
localities and states which um come
together in cyberspace
to create a certain atmosphere which
fatima said is an atmosphere of fear of
intimidation and ultimately lawlessness
because it says the law is not going to
protect the minorities um and the
knowledge dalits we also we have to talk
about that that there are people who are
not being protected by the law and they
are citizens of this country and it
really is a that is a huge problem if
there are large parts of the citizenry
that are unprotected by
the law and the constitution and i said
its heart this really has reignited the
debate about the rights of india's
minorities under the hindu nationalist
government hasn't it
uh yes it has and i will agree with what
i said it is the rule of law that is on
trial and i'll extend it to the fact
that it is quotes that are on trial
lately
see the democratic setup that is in
india that concern the courts become the
sentinel qv that is the custodian of the
constitution
um the minorities are protected by that
constitution and that constitution is
predicted by the courts but if the
courts look the other way or if they are
not actively
protecting minorities protecting those
who are endangered protecting those who
are obsessed
the situation will come to what it has
already come where anyone has the power
to heckle a muslim girl going to school
or going to college or if those voices
are raised those voices are shut down by
saying that uh
we also have a right to wear suffering
challenge i say no one is stopping you
from wearing that but you cannot take
away the light of a muslim woman to wear
wear that
hijab
so this is an attack on the identity
this is an attack
on the democratic and constitutional
setup of india
fatima we don't have a whole lot of time
left but let me just ask you do you
think that we're going to see these
protests and counter protests growing in
the weeks ahead
i think so i think so that in the last
few years if you remember 2020 the delhi
community violence the riots where
muslims were targeted at that point of
time it also started as uh you know a
bunch of people who support the
government to support the bjp starting
this counter protest against people who
were protesting muslims predominantly
protesting against the citizenship
amendment act um and that protest come
to protest it eventually snowballed or
was actively manufactured orchestrated
in such a way that it snowballs into a
right light situation in the national
capital um so i think until and unless
uh a court actively tries to intervene
and step in and give these women the
rights that they are demanding which are
basic basic rights um i'm afraid i'm
really really afraid of what this could
eventually snowball into all right well
we have run out of time so we're going
to have to leave the conversation there
thank you so much to all of our guests
fatima khan
chandra and anastanvir
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website al
and for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim jordan the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]
you